All right.
I know that you will know who I'm talking
about right away.
When I did tell
you that a fox news host did something surprising
and that it just made some sense, he told
the Fox News audience that they should actually
just go and read the Mueller report instead
of basing their opinion on what pundits say.
Definitely not on what William bars propaganda
letter set.
And obviously if you've watched the show before,
if you've watched Fox News before, you would
know that the anchor I'm talking about is
Shepard Smith who has occasionally pierced
the echo chamber of the Fox News audience.
Take a look still.
Nadler says the committee will have access
to some of the special council's most important
files and that's according to Natalie [inaudible],
including evidence of possible corruption
of justice.
Remember in his 400 plus page report that
everyone in America should read?
Everyone, Robert Mueller laid out 10 instances
of a parent obstruction of justice, criminal
obstruction of justice, potentially by president
Trump.
The special counselor did not exonerate.
The president said if they could have, they
would have, but they couldn't, so they didn't.
Molar explained that if he and his team had
confidence that the president did not commit
obstruction, they would've said so.
He also said that under Justice Department
guidelines, charging the president with the
crime was never an option to him.
He said the constitution requires another
process.
That's what he said.
10 instances of apparent obstruction, potentially
criminal did not exonerate Donald Trump would
have said Trump didn't do anything wrong.
If they knew Trump didn't do anything wrong,
justice guidelines prevented him from filing
charges.
Other options exist referencing of course,
impeachment.
How bad has the partisan media industrial
complex gotten that it's newsworthy when someone
says completely uncontroversial but true things
on Fox News that happened not to align with
the Republican president's position, and I
will go even further by the way about reading
the report.
I understand that this is my job and it's
not most people's, so reading a 450 page document
with 1500 1300 however many footnotes, I get
that that's not feasible for a lot of people,
but there's another option.
It's not just you read the 450 pages or you
go by the four page bar propaganda letter.
There is something called the Mueller summary
of the report.
It's not Mueller's report and it's not bars
letter.
These are executive summaries of the report.
Lawfare has these available, which we're linking
to if you're watching on youtube in the video
description down below, the Mueller report
itself is available as a free audio book on
audible.
We're linking to that down below on the youtube
clip.
Do What Fox News host Shepard Smith says.
It's crazy for me to be saying that.
Read the report and listen to the report,
whatever.
I've read almost the entire report.
I skipped over some of the parts that were
more kind of like context because if you already
know the context, I don't know that there
was that much more for me to learn from that,
but I've come away with much knowledge that
I could not have gotten from William bars
letter.
I certainly would not have gotten from Donald
Trump's characterization.
Number one, Russia's actions impacted the
election.
They successfully attacked election systems
period.
That is in the report.
Number two, there are lots of things that
probably should be criminal in our country
that aren't, and what I mean by that is that
there's a lot of indirect involvement with
criminal or potentially criminal activity
that is not a crime, including being a partner
to parties, committing crimes.
Even if you benefit from those crimes, even
if you had the sense that they were involved
in those crimes, if you're not actively coordinating
those crimes, a lot of that activity is not
criminal.
It probably should be.
And the problem we have in this country, and
I've said it before and this is just an example
of it on the street crime side, there is way
too much criminalization in our country.
If you look at the street crime that gets
people into jail and prison and into the system,
there is overcriminalization that has taken
place.
Conversely though on the white collar side,
on the corporate side, on the political crime
side, it's not criminal enough.
We don't have enough criminalization and that
is a broader issue that I've been talking
about for a long time here.
And of course a headline takeaway from reading
the actual Mueller report is that there is
substantial evidence meeting all three of
the requirements for criminal obstruction
of justice by Donald Trump or in other words,
uh, uh, on of the 14 possible obstructive
acts, eight of those according to the Mueller
report, meet all three of the requirements
to be criminally obstructive acts.
Read the report, okay, start the impeachment
inquiry further.
Publicize the contents.
It's time.
I don't know what anybody's waiting for